50 seconds of alleged Mass Effect
Andromeda footage is leaked and it
features jetpacks the short video which
appears to be a visual effects demo reel
of some kind was posted on NeoGAF by
user taker 34 who say they obtained it
from a quote certain developer who is
currently working on Andromeda the vid
shows off a variety of effects like rain
smoke and explosions but also features a
Krogan who's neutralizing a human before
another squad of three moves in and the
aforementioned jetpack for the player
character industry insiders shinobi
stuck his head into the gap thread to
say that quote this is around a late
2014 build it doesn't look like this now
and user y 0 64 noted that the HUD shown
in the video matches a behind-the-scenes
image posted on twitter by former senior
development director chris win in
November Andromeda was originally
scheduled to come out this holiday
season that has now reportedly been
pushed back to 2017 stay tuned to games
but where we'll keep you updated